I'm Eric Chu hotel Andre and I'm doing
the wired auto-complete interview she
would tell top top top one to sibilance
to Adele
what is Eric Andre desk made of yeah
it's been like it's not wood
it's like drywall and like asbestos what
is Eric Andre's mouth made of what does
Eric Andre famous work good question my
parents my parents asked that question
every day I did um eight episodes of 2
broke girls five years ago and you know
my career is never looked back
who is Eric Andre in the Lion King I am
a ZZ the hyena I've done voice acting
before I've never done voice acting in
the Lion King before that is the first
yeah I've done some cartoons and then I
did this cartoon put the 3d carried in
typically I'm calling it a cartoon
how did Eric Andre get his start I'm
kind of still waiting I'm paying student
loans how real is Eric Andre show we
never fake a reaction all the reactions
are real we're torturing the celebrity
guests and I do hidden-camera pranks
that's why I always do hidden-camera
pranks in the subway to prove to people
like this is not a soundstage okay
mmm what type of humor is Eric Andre
again that's what my parents ask me
every day
I don't know poop jokes what is Eric
Andre like in real life not as exciting
depressive and anxious what instrument
does Eric Andre play I went to school at
the Berklee College of Music in Boston
for upright bass
and I wasted a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars what is Eric Andre quad
that is kind of a typo does it make
sense
I think the quad is like the hangout on
a college campus I just played like
hacky sack for four years and wasted a
lot of money Eric Andre Froot Loops yep
I did a headache camera bit where I went
on the subway and one of those like dog
collar cones like when you neuter your
dog and then you don't want to look at
their stitches I put that on and I Ford
a bunch of fruit loops and milk in it
and I was like ladies and gentlemen
pardon the interruption I have bad news
I did not get the job at Froot Loops my
body is now your communion please eat
from me
and I was pouring milk and fruit lips
into my dog cone people did not like
that Eric Andre ranch ranch is a very
delicious condiment that I made more
popular with a stupid bit I do on the
show again these are just dumb I'm in
the business of dumb ideas can't spell
America now okay this is not correct
you can't spell the American dream
without Eric Andre in the middle of it
so if you spell out the words American
dream my name fits perfectly in the
center of it that's real life Eric Andre
can you explain this I sure can
where am I Eric Andre I wish somebody
that came out of the bathroom in the
bathroom right now look get out of my
room Eric Andre can I hold your baby yes
you can hold my baby Anytime Upgrade
there's ten more is Eric where is
Beyonce that's what the producers are
saying right now is Eric Andre a genius
yeah bro no I dropped out of DeVry is
Eric Andre Andre 3000 sure is Eragon dad
yeah I knew this is coming yes is Eric
Andre scripted no we have all the gags
and pranks like the thoroughly locked
and loaded
for the guest gets there so we have like
stunt people in the skies we built the
stage up so we can hide actors inside
and then like ghost peppers and habanero
peppers and their coffee and stuff like
that like it's like oh it's like a Saw
movie that's a nightmare where is Eric
Andre show filmed we filmed the
hidden-camera street pranks in New York
City and we film the studio in Los
Angeles there's more relaxed
hidden-camera laws in New York that's
the truth it's a single consent state
where does Eric Andre live I live in Los
Angeles
I'm from Boca Raton Florida where is
Eric Andre from ah I answered it bugger
Tom Florida it's God's waiting room and
I got out as soon as I possibly could
where did Eric Andre go to college ah
University of Phoenix online
great why is Eric Andre very existential
I don't know how to answer that
that's an existential conundrum what am
i John Paul Sartre my guard over
here went to a music school dude I got
my degree in three weeks
why did Aragon Drake change his band I
just like stopped doing my bond because
music is I like a point in this career
where you do like a ton of work and then
nobody gives you any money unless your
talent it's then they give you money why
did Eric Andre shout-out Christina
Applegate cuz come on man Kelly Bundy
was my first crush she's a national
treasure
why would Eric Andre why would I mean
not what would I mean why would I mean
why not you know what I mean well
interview is two people
we filmed something